nous allons entendre cet après midi
messieurs olivier ferrand et adrien
taquet sur le projet de loi de
bioéthique
cette audition je vous le rappelle fait
l'objet d'une captation en vidéo
messieurs les ministres ont vu de sa
retransmission sur le site du sénat où
elle sera ensuite disponible disponibles
à la demande nous annick aussi je
souhaite que vous preniez stade tous
simplement que le ministre selon des
rites et la santé doit nous quitter vers
18h15 18h30 18h15 et que monsieur tac et
donc pourra lui répondre par la suite la
suite des questions je vais
immédiatement donné la parole au
ministre pour un bref propos liminaire
afin de laisser le maximum de temps aux
échanges avec d'abord nos rapporteur
ensuite nos collègues monsieur véran
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président cher alain milon mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs où il devrait
vous laisser pas ce que je dois je suis
convoqué après dans un autre parlement à
l'assemblée nationale pour cette fois ci
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire donc je
suis ministre en charge de boue beaucoup
de sujets en ce moment ce qui fait à la
fois le côté passionnant du ministère
mais à la fois qui m'oblige parfois des
dédoublements quelque peu périlleux et
je ne voulais pas certainement pas
bâcler cette audition et je remercie
beaucoup adrien taquet qui prendra la
suite et qui a participé depuis le début
à l'élaboration du texte et l ensemble
des débats dans les deux chambres
donc le projet de loi bioéthique arrive
en deuxième lecture et c'est une bonne
chose
après un an de débats que je crois riche
passionnant avec des interrogations
sincère des doutes des convictions en
train de se forger des convictions qui
se sont forgé ou qui ont pu d'ailleurs
évolué au fil des débats
je souhaite d'abord vivement que ce
texte puisse être puisse être adoptée de
façon définitive avant l'été ce serait
une bonne chose car il est porteur de
droits nouveaux et que beaucoup de
français beaucoup de familles actuel ou
en devenir attendent que la loi soit
adoptée et promulguée applicables pour
pouvoir en bénéficier
le débat jeudi en première lecture a été
un débat qui était riche qu'il a été
aussi sereins et
effectuez des positions de chacun c'est
dans cet esprit que tous les membres du
gouvernement qui porte avec moi ce texte
envisage les prochains débats
sénatoriaux plus qu'un autre texte les
textes de bioéthique les lois de
bioéthique se contentent peu des
délégations de vote et des consignes de
ouf ce sujet ce rapport très subjectif
très personnel et très intime au texte à
des avantages je pense en particulier à
l'enrichissement de certaines
dispositions en première lecture par les
parlementaires
s'agissant par exemple des enfants
présentant des variations de
développement génitales ou la
réalisation en première intention d'un
examen des caractéristiques génétiques
chez le nouveau-né dans le cadre du
dépistage néonatal pour la recherche
d'anomalies moi même d'ailleurs j'étais
parlementaire en première lecture
j'étais ministre en charge en deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée nationale j'ai pu
ainsi aussi faire évoluer à la marge
mais un certain nombre de positions par
rapport à mes prédécesseurs sur ce texte
il a aussi des inconvénients qui
tiennent à la difficulté de conclure et
de nous dire à la fin voilà ce que
ledroit accepte de la science notre
responsabilité est grande elle n'est pas
écrasante mais elle nous oblige à faire
des choix
ces choix nous les ferons ensemble parce
que c'est au parlement et nulle part
ailleurs qu'ils doivent être faits
j'entends des questions sur le
calendrier la temporalité l'examen de ce
texte et je lisais je souhaite que la
navette puisse se poursuivre et qu'elle
puisse aboutir
j'observe à cet effet que si des
divergences subsistent sur l'extension
de la mp beaucoup plus de femmes des
hauts femmes seules celles ci se
concentreront davantage sur la prise en
charge que sur l'extension proprement
dit
le gouvernement a fait le choix il a été
salué de ne pas engager la procédure
accélérée ça signifie que nous prenons
le temps du débat mais aussi que
plusieurs lectures sont nécessaires
avant l'adoption définitive de ce projet
de loi je suis prêt à débattre des
dispositions de ce projet de répondre
est prêt à répondre à toutes vos
interrogations
une dernière remarque avant de conclure
afin dé c'est tout le temps en question
les équilibres défendu en première
lecture pour le gouvernement perdure
équilibre entre avancées sociales et
préservation des principes équilibre
entre ouverture des techniques permise
par les avancées scientifiques et
attachement au respect de l'être humain
dans leurs applications
l'irruption des techniques génétiques
interroge notre rapport à la médecine
aux patients et finalement à l'humain
avancer sans crainte n'est pas avancé à
n'importe quel prix quoi qu'il en coûte
nous sommes sur une ligne de crête entre
le possible et le souhaitable entre des
parcours individuels parfois douloureux
et des conséquences collectives
acceptable c'est l'honneur je le disais
du parlement que d'avoir à débattre de
sujets d'importance les principes
attaché aux dons de gamètes la poursuite
de la mp en cas de décès du conjoint
l'accès aux origines personnelles des
tests génétiques
chaque voix doit être entendue et enfin
discussions nous trouverons ensemble
j'en suis convaincu les bons équilibres
et les nuances utile pour un texte dont
chacun pourra être fier à texte qui
ouvrira de nouveaux droits
sans rien céder à nos valeurs je vous
remercie si vous m'y autorise
effectivement monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
nos dames et messieurs les sénateurs
très brièvement me permet tout d'abord
de vous présenter à toutes et à tous les
meilleurs voeux pour cette année 2021 je
formule le souhait qu'elle soit pour le
gouvernement mais aussi pour le
parlement pour le pour le sénat
l'occasion de poursuivre un effort
commun qui a si souvent porté ses fruits
le texte qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
on est d'ailleurs je pense pour
effectivement avoir participé en grande
partie des débats que ce soit
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat un
très bon exemple et je suis heureux que
nous puissions reprendre le travail
vraiment rigoureux qui nous avaient
occupé ici l'an dernier
même dans cette actualité qui nous
accapare nous sentons bien à nouveau à
quel point les sujets portés par ce
texte des passes à la fois les clivages
les clivages politiques
les polémiques du quotidien et à quel
point ces enjeux nous préoccupe tous
personnellement intimement parfois aussi
souvent sur ces sujets là et appelle en
même temps de nous une responsabilité
collective à la hauteur ces réflexions
ou thème tiennent peut-être d'autant
plus à coeur qu'elle renvoie souvent
dans ce texte à la prise en
considération de l'intérêt de l'enfant
et à la reconnaissance aussi de la
diversité de toute la diversité toute la
richesse et à l'égalité aussi des
modèles familiaux
autant de préoccupations que je sais
être largement partagé dans cette salle
même si la ville a demandé des débats et
qu'elles se poursuivront autant de
considérations qui ne peuvent attendre
et qu'on ne saurait repoussé je rejoins
cet égard le ministre olivier ferrand il
ya là la concrétisation des attentes
fortes de la société puis d'un langage
d'engagement clair du gouvernement nos
échanges permettront bien évidemment
olivier ferrand l'a rappelé le rappeler
de reparler parlant de l'extension
prévue de l'accès à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation la question de
l'accès un certain nombre de données
d'information pour les personnes nées
des mp ou ou dans le secret sous le
secret ou encore de la définition du
diagnostic prénatal
certains de ces sujets ont été récemment
abordé dans d'autres textes que ce soit
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale que
vous avez eu à débattre l'automne
l'automne dernier mais aussi de la
proposition de loi qui a été porté à
l'assemblée nationale par la députée
monique limon et qui est la traduction
d'un rapport qui avaient été
conjointement conduit par monique limon
mais aussi par la sénatrice la
rapporteure corinne imbert ici présenté
cette proposition doit viendra devant
vous prochainement je ne connais pas
encore je ne maîtrise pas évidemment
l'ordre du jour du sénat mais vous aurez
l'occasion de l'examiner évidemment
voilà ces initiatives c'est
approfondissement montre bien à quel
point le texte bioéthique ce qu'il
comprend est attendu et derrière le
ministre liger vers an c'est tout un
collectif gouvernementale avec nos deux
ministres garde des sceaux et ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur de
nombreuses administrations qui oeuvrent
à faire aboutir ce beau projet de loi
dans cette optique l'apport du sénat est
incontournable a été le sera
indispensable et nous nous réjouissons
de pouvoir en débattre encore avec vous
à compter d'aujourd'hui je vous remercie
merci beaucoup je vais immédiatement
puisque le temps que vous comptez passer
la parole ne rapportait en commençant
par madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président l droit
plusieurs questions doivent déposer une
par une les droits toutes les questions
je vous remercie ma ma première question
messieurs les ministres a trait à un
propos qui a été tenu par notre collègue
députée mme touraine qui est gamme en
inde et rapporteur de ce texte qui
indique vouloir je cite légitimer une
procréation sans sexe pour tous est-ce
aussi votre vision de l'évolution
sociétale que
vous voulez voir sanctionné par ce texte
est ma première question ma deuxième
question porte sur le fait que
simultanément l'assistance médicale à la
procréation va être étendue est
également votre souhait est de lever
l'anonymat pour les donneurs de gamètes
ce qui crée une crainte de pénurie en
raison de la simultanéité de ces deux
décisions
où en sommes-nous du stock existant et y
at il eu un impact de la crise qu vite
19 sur ce stock et enfin deux autres
questions d'ordre plus juridique
quelle est votre position sur la
gestation pour autrui sachant qu'elle
est actuellement interdite par le droit
français mais que par le biais des
transcriptions la jurisprudence
finalement contournent cette
interdiction
comment envisagez-vous cet élément et
dernière question sur la filiation il y
a eu des évolutions à l'assemblée
nationale sur la façon dont la filiation
pour les couples de femmes a été
envisagée il a notamment été rétabli le
fait que la mère était la femme qui
accouche ce qui est un peu le ba-ba de
la filiation maternelle mais elle est
obligée néanmoins de reconnaître cette
enfance qui est une régression par
rapport au droit existant le sénat avait
proposé des techniques de filiation qui
étaient directement inspirée de ce qui
existait déjà
pourquoi s'y opposer je remercie vous
répondez où je fais l'ensemble des rames
devaient rapporteur comme il me plait
monsieur juillet merci monsieur
président donc s'il plaît à monsieur le
président je voudrais juste en
introduction avant de poser trois
questions faire de petites remarques
la première si je voudrais saluer le
travail sur les articles dont je suis
rapporteur de l'assemblée nationale de
leurs collègues de l'assemblée nationale
qui ont retenu un certain nombre des
dispositions y compris des dispositions
importantes que nous avions adopté dans
l'hémicycle certains articles ont été
voté conforme d'ailleurs et voilà et je
trouve qu'il ya une co-construction
législatives qui en l'occurrence et a
démarré sur des bases de qualité je
parle encore une fois sur les articles
dont je suis le rapporteur
et ce qui témoigne de la nécessité de
prendre du temps pour bien faire la loi
encore encore une fois ma deuxième
remarque vise le propos général de du
ministre de la santé
ce texte tout le monde l'a constaté a
été cette révision des lois de
bioéthique accueille donc une réforme
qui n'était pas nécessairement inscrit
dans la loi de bioéthique mais qui n'est
pas illégitime non plus dans la loi de
bioéthique la réforme de la mp l'aide
médicale à la procréation et ça a nourri
un discours un discours politique d'
équilibre d'ensemble du texte qui est en
gros voilà une réforme progressiste
d'ouverture de nouveaux droits
et quand il ya équilibre et bien
forcément de l'autre côté il ya une
position qui est moins ouverte et moi je
regrette que sur les questions
généralement de recherche et de
recherche génomique le texte dans son
état actuel ne soit pas un texte de très
grande ouverture et je crois que ça fait
qu d'ailleurs sur ces questions de
recherche à l'état actuel de la
recherche française on a d'abord on en
parle beaucoup sur le co vide et sur ce
que produit notre pays durant l'examen
de la loi de bioéthique nous sommes nous
avons beaucoup évoqué la nouvelle
technique en recherche génomique du
christ père casse 9 les français ont
découvert que c'est une française qui a
mis au point cette technique mais
qu'elle est partie qu'elle a quitté
notre pays et qu'elle a expliqué
pourquoi elle avait quitté notre pays et
je crains que ce texte dans son état
actuel ne répondent pas à la nécessité
de donner à nos chercheurs la capacité
de travailler sereinement dans notre
pays j'en viens à mes trois questions
monsieur le président
donc la première c'est que nous avions
introduit sur la question du don
d'organes la création d'un statut de
donneurs d'organes dont je dois dire
avec vraiment très avec beaucoup
d'humilité que nous avons conscience des
limites de ce que nous proposons de
l'ain perfecta l'un perfectibilité total
de ce que nous avons proposé mais nous
sommes dans une situation il faut
actionner tous les leviers pour
progresser sur cette question
du don d'organes l'assemblée nationale a
souhaité supprimer notre proposition et
vous avez semble-t-il approuvé cette
suppression comment est ce que vous vous
quelles propositions comptez vous faire
à ce moment là si vous ne retenez pas
encore une fois la création ce statut de
donneurs d'organes et d'une
reconnaissance symbolique qui soit plus
forte sans qu'il n'y ait de contrepartie
je voudrais pas le débat là dessus mais
on en est tous d'accord là dessus
deuxièmement nous avons ouvert le don du
sang mineur de 17 ans l'assemblée
nationale l'avait fait dans une
proposition de loi qui avait été votée à
l'initiative de damien abad en 2018 et
l'assemblée nationale cette fois ci a
souhaité revenir sur cette disposition
nous avons entendu les explications du
président lors d'une audi notre audition
d'ailleurs du président de
l'établissement français du sang des
arguments techniques je veux dire qu'il
ne nous conviennent qu'ils ne nous
paraît pas pertinent et pas de voir
impacté et remettre en cause cette
ouverture or là aussi vous avez fait
votre les objections de l'établissement
français du sang où je rappellerai très
rapidement les jeunes feraient plus de
malaises vagaux il serait plus exposé à
des carences en fer
et puis une question très technique sur
l'autorisation des parents qui serait ce
donc là aussi j'aimerais avoir votre
votre précision
et puis dernièrement troisième et
dernier point vous avez fait adopter
alors là contre l'avis de la commission
spéciale de l'assemblée nationale et
nous avions nous dans l'hémicycle même
avis vous avez fait adopter donc un
amendement la france insoumise qui vise
à rétablir la présomption de
consentement
dans le cas du don post mortem des
personnes bénéficiant d'une mesure de
protection juridique avec représentation
relative à la personne et cette
présomption de consentement nous paraît
être là sur un meuble en éthique
extrêmement contestable donc cet
amendement de la france insoumise a été
adopté avec
votre soutien vous pouvez vous nous
expliquer votre position j'en ai assez
merci bien madame hébert va prendre la
suite
merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs les ministres 3,3 question si
vous le permettez
tout d'abord en première lecture le
sénat à 1 ouvert la possibilité de
rechercher dans le cadre du dépistage
néonatal que vous évoquez dans vos
propos liminaire monsieur le ministre
les anomalies génétiques cible est
listée par arrêté du ministre la santé
s'agit de dépister des anomalies à
l'origine de pathologies très grave qui
font aujourd'hui l'objet de thérapie
génique prometteuse qui représente un
véritable gain de chance pour les
personnes concernées
à condition que ces thérapies soit
administré un stade précoce jeunes
enfants idéalement avant l'apparition
des premiers symptômes
donc je me félicite que le gouvernement
ait conservé cet objectif en deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée le dépistage
néonatal devenant ainsi un programme de
santé national avec une base légale
pourriez vous nous indiquer si à
l'avenir des affections génétiques
telles que certaines formes
d'amyotrophie spinale infantile pourront
bien faire partie de la liste des
maladies recherché dans ce cadre afin de
permettre la prise en charge la plus
précoce possible des enfants concernés
deuxième deuxième question l'été dernier
devant l'assemblée nationale vous avez
annoncé le lancement dès l'automne 2020
d'un projet de recherche multicentrique
sous la forme d'un programme hospitalier
de recherche clinique dans sept centres
hospitaliers
concernant le diagnostic
préimplantatoire le contexte sanitaire
at il permis le lancement de ce projet
de recherche dans les délais prévus et
quelles sont ses principaux objectifs
et puis 3e troisième question qui
concerne diagnostic préimplantatoire
avec recherche d'un applaudi
ceci a été introduit par le sénat en
première lecture contre l'avis du
gouvernement
supprimée en deuxième lecture à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
pourriez revenir au delà des reproches
qui ont été faits sur sur ce sujet la
même façon un peu je vais dire primaire
revenir sur ce qui vous gêne sur ce
sujet là sur le diagnostic en rendant
possible diagnostic préimplantatoire
avec recherche d'un applaudi merci bien
monsieur hainaut pour conclure le cycle
des rapporteurs
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les les ministres monsieur le ministre
vous avez parlé de ligne de crête dans
votre propos préliminaires et je crois
que c'est un terme qui convient bien à
ce qui concerne la recherche sur les
embryons transgénique où les embryons
chimérique on a d'ailleurs eu des
discussions assez approfondies sur ces
questions en commission spéciale et puis
lors de la séance plénière du sénat
on est naturellement partager chaque
collègue en conscience s'interroge parce
qu'il ya un versant où on se dit
peut-être qu'on peut améliorer la vie
sains et la fin de leur taupe et 10
froide par exemple comme ça nous a été
cité et puis il ya un autre versant où
on craint de bouleverser la vie sains et
notamment lorsqu'on lorsque on a en
évoque le
le génome alors ma première question les
toute simple quelle est la doctrine du
gouvernement pour ce qui concerne cette
question de la recherche sur les
embryons transgénique est chimérique
sachant que bien évidemment il s'agit
ici d'une loi bioéthique en france
ici au parlement au sénat mais c'est un
problème bien plus large qu'on ne peut
pas seulement regarder à l'échelle de
nos frontières et la deuxième question
sera plus plus plus précise elle
concerne l'article 12 et notamment là
vous avez continué à exclure la
possibilité de recourir à l'imagerie
cérébrale fonctionnelle pour ce qui
concerne l' expertise judiciaire
est ce qu'il ya des éléments probants
sur certains cas d'utilisation qui ont
été abusifs et qui vous ont fait qui ont
poussé l'assemblée nationale a à prendre
cette décision je vous remercie
merci bien je vous laisse répondre cette
salve de questions de terminer de noter
la dernière question il y en a beaucoup
je crois qu'on fait même un tour assez
globale des grands enjeux du tac y en a
d'autres je suis pas compétent pour
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
avez posé mesdames et messieurs sénateur
je suis ministre en charge des
solidarités de la santé certaines
questions vous avez abordé relève du
garde des sceaux
d'autres la ministre de la recherche
vaine et sans néanmoins ayant suivi dans
la globalité le texte me risquer à des
réponses mais qui seront forcément moins
technique et pointu que celle qu aurait
fait mais mes collègues ministres s'il
avait été à mes côtés
d'abord pour la madame la sénatrice
jourda vous poser près une question
philosophique initial de la procréation
sans sexe pour tout ça on sait pas une
expression que j'ai employé mais vous
avez signalé que c'était un député de
l'assemblée nationale qui avait employé
cela ben moi je vais vous dire le fond
de ma pensée je suis pas du tout
transhumanistes même vraiment pas
transhumanistes je suis plutôt
pragmatique en l'occurrence et je
considère mais c'est le cadre général
des lois de bioéthique ça rejoint un peu
une remarque du sénateur juillet souvent
la loi galope après la société on a
souvent beaucoup de retard on peut
conseiller du retard d'ailleurs pas mais
souvent on constate que la loi entérine
des pratiques existantes le cas de la
pma pour les femmes seules ou pour les
couples de femmes est emblématique
c'est plus d'une décennie que les femmes
qui souhaitent seul ou en couple
bénéficier d'une pma et fonder une
famille avoir un enfant peuvent le faire
la seule condition c'est qu'elle est
suffisamment d'argent pour pouvoir le
faire à l'étranger
et ça c'est pas acceptable donc parfois
je dis pas que tout ce qui est interdit
doit être autorisé sous presse où reese
sous peu sous en raison du fait que ce
serait pratiquée je sais juste qu'il ya
des pratiques qui sont entérinées dans
la société et qui ne sont pas entériné
dans le droit moi je n'ai aucune
difficulté à reconnaître le droit pour
les femmes qu'elles soient seuls ou en
couple de pouvoir bénéficier d'une pma
aucune difficulté ce qui veut pas dire
que je n'irai tout des stouts
différenciation sexuelle et que je
n'irai à la fois le rôle parental social
parental biologique et cédera donc je
n'irai pas si vous m'y autorise aidant
dans ce type de débat j'ai ma propre
conception mes propres convictions mais
je suis un progressiste pragmatique je
ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'on aille au
bout des idées que je pourrais porter
dans un texte de bioéthique s'est peu
aussi pour répondre aux sénateurs
jonnier et une loi de bioéthique par
définition elle est faite pour évoluer
puisqu'elle est révisé tous les cinq ans
et donc peut-être qu'on peut trouver que
l'intervalle de cinq ans est long je
pense que c'est un intervalle qui est
déjà suffisant en tout cas compte tenu
du fait que ce texte est lui-même dans
le circuit depuis depuis plus de deux
ans sur la question maintenant très
pratique du stock de gamètes et yat-il
pénurie de gamètes
c'est un risque on est déjà en plus
tendue ce soit sur les spermatozoïdes ou
sur les ovocytes un risque qu'on prend
très au sérieux
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait du tout de
baisse de donneurs avec la question
d'accès aux origines
pas du tout même et d'ailleurs c'est
confrontés aux faits parce que d'autres
pays l'ont fait qu'ils n'ont pas
rencontré de diminution des donneurs
parfois même c'était plutôt l'inversé le
dos une pratique est encore confidentiel
les campagnes de recrutements se font à
minima il faut qu on insiste il faut
qu'on promeuvent le don qui est un acte
généreux avec un acte altruiste et je
crois pas du tout que la loi soit amené
à réduire davantage le nombre de gamme
est disponible sur la question de la gpa
et de la jurisprudence c'est arrivé a eu
de très très long débat sur cette
question là l'assemblée et au sénat
le gouvernement est opposé à la pratique
de la gpa le gouvernement est opposé au
principe d'un enfant qui te qui seraient
apatrides de fait
faute de pouvoir les reconnaître mais je
vois qu adrien taquet prépare le micro
je je je le laisse compléter oui non
juste pour pour compléter là dessus et
répondra aussi à la qualification
suivante sur les questions de filiation
effectivement de nombreuses reprises les
membres différents membres du
gouvernement au banc et à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat ont pu affirmer
l'opposition du gouvernement à la gpa
par les deux lignes rouges pour nous et
nous le réitérons je pense ici ici
devant vous vous avez parlé de
jurisprudence qui permettait qui
permettrait de contourner cela à
l'assemblée nationale me semble-t-il en
seconde lecture nous avons introduit un
amendement qui permet justement de
contrevenir à une réponse de la cour de
cassation est par contre d'être en
conformité par ailleurs à ce que disait
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
puisque
elle demandait ce que des procédures
filiation puisse être puisse être mise
en oeuvre d'une part et avec une
certaine célérité
d'autre part et nous avons confirmé
notamment la voie de l'adoption par ce
pur pour ce faire étant entendu que dans
la pratique peut-être il est vrai le
critère de célérité n'a pas toujours été
a été rempli et que nous évertuons à
queue et que cela soit le cas cela soit
le cas
voilà en tout état de cause sa gestion
des transcriptions judiciaire c'est
toujours sous l'autorité du juge
évidemment en prenant en considération
l'intérêt de l'enfant et la prise en
considération les conditions dans
lesquelles l'enfant a pu être conçue
notamment l'appréciation du projet
parental ou on est pour ception et puis
au moment de l'examen de la situation
sur ces aspects là le gouvernement n'a
pas évolué a été conforme je crois à la
position qu'il avait dès le départ et et
s'était évertué au fil des lectures à
maintenir cette position sur la
filiation pas de tomates ici tu es sur
la transcription c'est toujours une fois
encore sous contrôle judiciaire et avec
la vérification des conditions de
conception de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
ah pardon sur cet aspect là si vous
pouviez répéter votre question ce qui
effectivement comme c'était lié à la gpa
jeu
et le fait que le sénat ait repris les
modalités d'établissement la filiation
existants alors que on a clairement
inventer quelque chose à l'assemblée
nationale comme une filiation
indivisible ce qui n'a jamais existé en
droit est ce qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
nécessaire
pourquoi madame est servie de très longs
débats et c'est vraiment de ça relève de
la compétence du garde des sceaux
je crois qu'il est temps en ce moment
auditionné par la commission des lois
dont qu'il peut pas être ici mais la
commission des lois du sénat
donc on peut sans doute mal goupillé
mais c'est lui qui était au banc il ya
un équilibre qui a été trouvé avec la
rapporteure et l'ensemble des d une
majorité de parlementaires présents en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
sur un équilibre c'est un texte qui en
portent beaucoup de conséquences en
droit avec une technicité elle que je ne
peux m'approprier ici dans le cas de
cette audition je le comprends monsieur
le ministre à ça n'a effectivement pas
votre rôle lorsque j'ai voulu en parler
avec le garde des sceaux un rendez-vous
m'a été refusée il est dommage que
personne ne puisse échanger sur ce point
qui comme vous le dites est un point
important
s'agissant du droit de la filiation je
prends je prends bonne note je lui
transmettrai mais encore une fois il
aurait pu être avec nous s'il n'avait
pas été lui-même convoqué par la
commission des lois au même moment
encore une fois on est à la disposition
du parlement mais on n'a pas légaliser
le clonage ni des ministres ni les
français ça fait plus l'objet du projet
de loi mais je lui transmettrai
évidemment non mais du projet très très
[Musique]
fort et le rapporteur le sénateur joe me
est ce que on est assez progressif sur
la recherche en génomique là aussi si
frédéric vidal était là elle vous
répondrais mieux que moi on peut avoir
chacun nos convictions et le sentiment
sur le ce que c'est que le progressisme
en recherche génomique toujours est il
qu on ouvre quand même un certain nombre
de cadres et de porte pour pouvoir faire
progresser la recherche je crois qu'il
ya des ce texte est porteur de cette
ambition là et que beaucoup d'ailleurs
d'ambition j'y reviendrai sur le dpi à
ne relèvent pas du droit
en tout cas ne relève pas de la loi mais
peuvent être autorisées par
l'expérimentation et la recherche
scientifique elle même pas de statut a
conféré aux donneurs d'organes je suis
pas favorable à ce qu'on donne un statut
particulier à une journée nationale des
donneurs d'organes
on sensibilise on communique on
accompagne les donneurs d'organes comme
mais la neutralité financière est un
principe important et je crois aussi que
la neutralité tout court vis-à-vis de
l'acte du don est un principe important
donc je suis pas favorable pour leur
donner un statut particulier la question
du don de sang à des mineurs est une
question qui est compliqué j'avais
commis un rapport pour le compte du
premier ministre de l'époque jean marc
ayrault en 2013 sur la filière du sang
et j'avais eu à me prononcer sur le don
du sang des mineurs spontanément j'ai
été plutôt favorable et en discutant et
en rencontrant et en auditionnant les
fédérations de donneurs mais aussi des
fédérations un certain nombre de malades
qui reçoivent des produits issus du dont
la conviction s'est forgée que ce
n'était pas une bonne idée
il ya plusieurs raisons à cela alors il
ya une première raison qui malgré tout
est une raison somatiques dans le sens
où quand vous êtes mineur 17 ans eh bien
vous êtes a plus à risque de développer
des malaises cardiaques parce que vous
pouvez voir une corpulence qui est assez
assez fragile et donc il faut protéger
ces personnes mais vous avez un argument
que juridique qui me semblent déjà en
lui-même suffire puisque nous gardons
nous avons débattu et nous débattons
d'ailleurs dans la loi de bioéthique de
la question de l'auto questionnaire qui
penche sur les pratiques sexuelles des
individus or une personne mineure de
recueillir l'accord de ses parents dans
le cadre de l'activité sanitaire en
rapport avec le sanitaire et donc il
faut aussi pouvoir préserver l'intimité
de la personne
quand elle va donner son sang est une
personne mineure qui ré donner son sang
serait finalement
je dirais exposés au risque que ses
parents en est à reconnaître sur ses
propres pratiques sexuelles ne serait ce
que parce que si à l'issue du
questionnaire
il ne pouvait pas donner son sang
finalement et bien ça mettrait la puce à
l'oreille de ses parents il ya plusieurs
raisons qui ont été évoqués encore une
fois par les associations de donneurs de
recevoir je ne sais pas si vous avez
auditionné ou si vous comptez le faire
je crois que leur position n'a pas
changé
année après année sur ce sujet sur la
présomption de consentement post mortem
pour le don d'organes c'est là aussi
moi j'avais auditionné il ya quelques
années cela des des responsables
d'associations qui milite pour faciliter
le don d'organes et j'avais rencontré
des médecins coordonnateurs de cellules
de prélèvement multi organes ainsi que
des infirmières de qui s'occupe de
contacter les familles etc et on se rend
compte qu'ils divergent
une divergence assez importante entre le
souhait exprimé par les français quand
on leur pose la question de 6 après
votre si vous êtes en état de mort
cérébrale êtes vous favorable à ce qu'on
prélève des organes et le taux de refus
par la famille lorsque la personne est
en mort cérébrale et qu'on lui pose la
question
dans l'idéal chacun remplirait des
consignes pour que les choses soient
claires mais on sait très bien que ce
n'est pas la pratique et de fait cette
divergence je ne sais plus le
pourcentage mais était vraiment
important le taux de refus est beaucoup
plus important quand on pose la question
à la famille que si on avait posé la
personne de son vivant et donc ça veut
dire que c'est autant d'organes qu'on ne
peut prélever et qu'on ne peut donc pas
greffé et autant de vies qu'on ne peut
pas améliorer voire sauver donc oui nous
avons donné un avis le gouvernement a
donné un avis favorable à cet amendement
que j'aurais pu à titre personnel moi
même déposé dans le cadre de ce projet
de loi sur pour madame la rapporteure
madame la sénatrice imbert sur le
dépistage néonatal peut-on avoir une
extension vers des maladies telles que
l'amyotrophie spinale infantile
il ya des maladies qu'ils n'étaient pas
curable génétique et qu'il le devienne
avec ma thérapie génique notamment
l'amyotrophie spinale fait partie de ces
maladies qui sont devenus curable j'ai
eu à accompagner des familles dont un
des enfants était atteint de cette
pathologie est le 2ème pouvait
éventuellement bénéficier et ce sont des
gens qui militent pour qu'on puisse
faciliter la recherche et de dépistage
il faut d'abord qu'on puisse être en
capacité avant de définir quels sont les
types de pathologies qu'on peut dépister
de titres systématique parce qu'elle va
équiper avoir dépistage ciblé sur ce que
vous avez une suspicion mais avant
d'avoir un dépistage systématique je
pense qu'il faut procéder de la même
manière que ce qui a été fait s'agissant
de troubles métaboliques la
phénylcétonurie par exemple ou
l'insuffisance surrénalienne à la
naissance il faut déjà avoir un certain
nombre d'enfants atteints de cette
pathologie disposer d'un traitement et
d'un moyen diagnostic clair mais moi
j'ai envie de vous dire je reviens à ma
position pragmatique initial je n'ai pas
envie et comme médecin c'est assez
spontané naturel de limiter dans nos
capacités à dépister des maladies qui
peuvent emporter des conséquences
sanitaires terrible sur sur les enfants
qui viennent de naître ou à naître et
qui pourrait être durable donc c'est à
la science de faire son chemin et de
faire ses propositions le cadre légal de
la recherche
il est amené à évoluer de manière à
faciliter un certain nombre de
dépistages jus passion qu'il fallait
inscrire dans le droit et dans le marbre
de la loi une liste déterminé de
pathologie de maladie sans quoi il
faudra à chaque fois la loi pour le
faire évoluer
sur la question du dpi et poser la
question du ph hercé au projet programme
hospitalier de recherche clinique
il est prévu pour durer 30 mois en terme
de durée de recrutement pas eu de
traitement et de suivi de 18 mois durée
globale de recherche 48 mois date de fin
de la recherche à septembre 2025
donc je ne peux pas vous donner de
résultat évidemment sur cette question à
la fin 2020 le projet n'a pas encore été
autorisé par l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
le premier dépôt de dossier a été
effectuée en novembre 2020
les demandes de précisions ont été
soumises aux investigateurs
elles portent particulièrement sur les
critères d'exclusion qui écarte à ce
stade les patientes aux antécédents de
fausses couches spontanées et d'échecs
d'implantation
mais ça va bouger sur le dpi est une
question qui est très complexe on a eu
un très très très long débat à
l'assemblée nationale en deuxième
lecture avec des majorités qui ont pu le
tangue et puis finalement qui se sont
figés de façon assez forte pour en
rester à ce qui était la proposition du
gouvernement à savoir la recherche
clinique telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du du projet
de recherche clinique
pourquoi moi j'avais soumis j'avais fait
un raisonnement qui était le suivant le
projet de recherche clinique qui peut
démarrer tôt il va concerner sept
centres et il nous permettra d'avoir des
résultats rapides qui permettront de
savoir si oui ou non c'est bien et ça
peut être utile et dans quelles
conditions
j'avais dit aux sénateurs le projet de
recherche clinique
il va juste pas s'il est en cours il va
démarrer on a dit et donc ça nous
permettra d'avoir des résultats plus
rapides et avoir des réponses à nos
questions de façon plus rapide et
pragmatique et si on devait entériner
dans la loi une pratique à laquelle se
refuse un certain nombre de
professionnels parce qu'il préfère
d'abord l'expérimenté et en fin de
compte j'ai vu ce raisonnement qui
consistait à dire si vous êtes contre le
dpi a voté contre l'article qui
autoriserait le dpi à dans la loi si
vous êtes pour le dpi a voté contre
aussi parce que le ph rc ira plus vite
et donc finalement il ya eu une majorité
qui pour pouvoir en rester aux phrc je
crois que c'est une position de
pragmatisme
pour le sénateur monsieur le sénateur
hainaut
mais poser des questions sur les
embryons transgénique est chimérique je
vous avoue que c'était vraiment la
partie de madame la ministre de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
je voudrais pas me risquer sur un
terrain je ne maîtriseraient pas
parfaitement donc je propose de lui
transmettre vos questions si vous le
souhaitez pour qu'elle puisse y apporter
une réponse avant l'examen du texte
pardon pour ça quant au recours à des
techniques de diagnostic à visée
neurologique
dans le cadre de procédures judiciaires
je cherchais si j'avais mes éléments que
je me remette ça à jour pour la nature
précise des examens qui était en cause
si vous me permettez je vous y répond
juste après la prochaine salve de
questions parce que j'étais la dernière
j'ai pas eu le temps de faire peut-être
essayer de monsieur me substituer au
garde des sceaux et qui l'occasion de
vous apporter des réponses en séance
mais juste pour peut-être vous apporter
quelques éléments at on si j'ai bien
appréhender la question est-ce que vous
soulevez vous évoquiez le système de
reconnaissance conjointe anticipé devant
notaire que vous avez présenté comme un
recul ar effectivement ça a été c'est le
système qui a été adoptée pour assurer
la filiation des deux membres du couple
à ça peut paraître comme un instrument
un recul ont trouvé un peu étonnant
effectivement du point de vue de la mère
biologique mais ça a des vertus
effectivement de simplification d'une
part pour les deux membres du couple et
c'est une démarche commune qui est à
skis et auxquelles procèdent chacun des
deux membres du couple pour reconnaître
l'enfant avec la filiation soit assurée
voilà je pense que c'est ça qui a guidé
cette suite simplification notamment
pour ne pas avoir à passer par
l'adoption pour la femme qui elle n'est
pas la mère biologique c'est ce qui a
motivé c'est le dispositif qui a été en
tout cas déterminé pour assurer à faire
face à ce genre de situation voilà voilà
pour ces premiers éléments est donc ce
n'est pas perçu comme un recul mais au
contraire est plutôt une avancée et une
simplification pour assurer la filiation
de mort envers les deux mais deux
membres du couple au vallon
merci pour l'instant j'ai quatre
collègues inscrit un cinquième bien
s'inscrire
je passe la parole à madame cohen de
rance pow wow merci monsieur le
président et merci messieurs les
ministres moi je me réjouis que ce texte
puisse venir en seconde lecture avec ses
vrais du retard mais on est quand même
dans une situation particulière avec
cette cette pandémie
donc il ya un certain nombre de
questions qui ont été déjà été posée
j'aimerais avoir quelques précisions
messieurs les ministres parce que
effectivement plusieurs de mes collègues
d'en souligner vous l'avez souligné on
l'a dit dans les débats dans parmi les
mesures il y en a une qui était très
attendue depuis au moins dix ans c'était
donc l'ouverture de la pma à toutes les
femmes même si on doit pas se focaliser
là dessus parce que la loi de bioéthique
et bien au delà de cette simple c'est de
simples mesures mais je voudrais quand
même avoir à part par rapport à
l'article 4 quelques précisions parce
que en même temps et maintenu un régime
dérogatoire ça a été un peu souligné en
matière de filiation justement pour les
enfants nés par pma et même si la
rédaction actuelle évolue enfin a évolué
tout à fait positivement par rapport à
la version initiale le fait de quand
même créé deux régimes différents entre
les couples hétérosexuels et les couples
lesbiens institut obligatoirement une
discrimination et non reconnaissance à
parfaite égalité de ses féminines donc
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment et
savoir comment est ce qu'on peut parce
que vous pensez qu'il est possible
plutôt de faire évoluer positivement les
choses pour éliminer faire reculer cette
cette discrimination
ma deuxième question c'est j'ai aussi
moins de contenu et à trois questions à
priori c'est la règle mais ma deuxième
question c'est que notre groupe le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste avait fait adopter un
amendement de suppression de l'article
17 sur la création d'embryons chimérique
ou transgénique
parce que nous avions
estimé je vous savez de partager ça
avait été partagée par don que c'était
dangereux et l'assemblée nationale est
revenu sur cette suppression
en proposant effectivement une nouvelle
rédaction
mais cette nouvelle rédaction nous
semble encore quand même plutôt plutôt
dangereuse car elle laisse la porte
ouverte en quelque sorte
et est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'on
peut encore faire enfin j'espère qu'on
peut encore faire bouger bouger
ce texte est enfin ma dernière question
concerne plus particulièrement l'article
21 10 sur les traitements destinés aux
enfants qui présentent une variation de
développement génitales qui reste donc
permise
et même si là encore la rédaction a
évolué il semblerait que cette rédaction
reste quand même un suffisamment clair
je dirais et est insuffisamment
contraignante fasse finalement ce qu'on
peut appeler des mutilations sexuelles
génitales imposé donc là encore est ce
que vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir
évolution dans le bon sens toujours dans
l'intérêt est évidemment des populations
dont on parle
je vous remercie merci nous allons
passer en visioconférence avec monsieur
de lège denis delage est le président
lorsque vous m'entendez très bien le
gouvernement a souhaité favoriser le
congé paternité en réformant le congé
parental et en incitant les pères à
partager ce congé avec les maires ce qui
est une bonne chose et en justifiant
cela par l'importance et la présence du
père est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
contradiction avec la paternité qui
n'existerait plus mais c'est double
maternité donc l'absence du père dans ce
projet de droit je voudrais que le
gouvernement puisse m'éclairer sur ce
qui m'apparaît être une contradiction
merci
merci monsieur de la jeune la parole
était monsieur mohamed assouali merci
monsieur le président merci messieurs
les ministres pour vos éclairages la
question que je voulais poser était
relative aux ppp hrc et le dpa et dans
la rapporteure en berlin a pousé j'en ai
une autre en réserve
si vous demandez messieurs les ministres
si vous pouvez nous donner un calendrier
prévisible de l'entrée en vigueur de des
premières pma pour les couples de femmes
est-ce qu'il serait envisageable que
d'ici la fin de cette année on puisse
avoir les premières pré paiement
c'est pas de la domination que je vous
demande mais après le calendrier
parlementaire est ce que on pourrait
avoir un agenda prévisible merci merci
bien je vous laisse répondre à cette
première salve après il restera quatre
collègues pour l'instant adrien taquet
qui pour la question s'ouvre le il y
avait plusieurs questions qui relevait
la question du sénateur de legge
notamment la rue il y avait un point sur
la tronche de filiation un point sur le
conte veiller sur le congé paternité sur
le père et congé paternité qui est je
vous le rappelle un congé paternité
d'accueil d'accueil du jeune du jeune
enfant qui effectivement en loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale a été a
été adoptée à l'unanimité à la
quasi-unanimité même ici je crois en ses
séances avec un doublement du congé
paternité avec l'introduction d'une
semaine obligatoire pour l'instant j'ai
il m'a semblé entendre dans la question
qui était question de réformer le congé
parental pour qu'il soit davantage
partagée par les deux des deux membres
du couple car ce n'est pas encore à
quelque chose qui est encore été qui a
encore été mis à l'étude ni ni travaillé
pour l'instant peut-être que
effectivement ça le sera dans l'est dans
les semaines ou les mois à venir puisque
c'était une recommandation notamment de
la commission cyrulnik autour des 1000
premier jour de l'enfant sur cet aspect
là et sur la question du du père on sait
bien vous savez qu'il ya un certain
nombre
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune étude qui
n'a été menée qui a pu montrer que
l'absence enfin que le développement de
l'enfant puisque c'est ça le point de
départ qui est le
le notw est en tout cas peut-être le
mieux est un peu plus encore
c'est une monde que le développement de
l'enfant n'est pas altéré dans le cadre
d'un couple homoparental ou si on est
uniquement avec un de ses parents
pendant ces c'est ses jeunes années
ce qui compte c'est l'altérité c'est on
a tous des liens d'attachement multiples
qui nous ont faits qui nous ont façonné
des les plus jeunes années de notre vie
et ce n'est pas tant le genre deux des
membres du couple d de nos parents qui a
un impact à cet égard donc il ya pas de
contradiction
notre foi on semble que l'un comme
l'autre sont des progrès sociétaux
importants attendus par nos concitoyens
à la fois effectivement l'extension du
congé paternité et l'ouverture aux
couples de femmes et aux femmes seules
de laisser dans ce médicale à la
procréation alors écrit tillon sur
l'article 21 bis madame la sénatrice
cohen lors de la première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
il y a eu de nombreux amendements qui
venaient de différents partis politiques
avaient été déposés sur sur ce sujet là
ceux visant à interdire les actes
chirurgicaux précoce en l'absence
d'urgence du ca vital ne pouvait être
acceptée
le gouvernement a pu donner un avis
favorable à l'amendement du député
gérard qui prévoyait la prise en charge
systématique des enfants présentant une
variation du développement génitales par
les équipes pluridisciplinaires
spécialisée dans le cadre d'une
concertation qui vise l établir le
diagnostic et les propositions
thérapeutiques possibles y compris
l'abstention thérapeutique et leurs
conséquences à un amendement qui a été
adopté à une très large majorité qui
s'inscrit selon nous parfaitement dans
l'esprit des recommandations qui avait
pu être formulées par
cca ne s'était la vie 132 et qui avait
fait suite à une saisine de noms de nos
services et une rédaction qui nous
semble équilibré un amendement qui
correspond également la ligne proposés
défendue par le ministère à l'issue
d'une série d'entretiens que nous avions
conduit l'année dernière entre avril et
juin 2019 avec les différentes parties
prenantes et notamment des médecins
experts ou des associations qui sont
plutôt en pointe a investi sur c'est sur
ces questions là je pense à amnesty
international la surrénale ou encore jss
alter corpus et et ceir voilà donc la
rédaction qui a été adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale nous semble être
être équilibré et satisfaisante en tout
cas à nos cieux il reste à répondre à la
question du calendrier pour deux pour le
docteur le sénateur le sol calendrier en
travaillant en temps masqué et en
parallèle de deux des débats sur les
textes d'application de la loi pour
qu'il puisse sortir vite
donc si la loi était adoptée en lecture
définitive avant l'été
on pourrait en sortir les textes
d'application dans la foulée
immédiatement alors il ya la saisine du
conseil constitutionnel si
constitutionnel peut prendre quelques
semaines
ensuite on promulgue que la loi les
textes d'application peuvent sortir très
vite l'idée qu' on puisse lancer les
parcours de pma effectivement dans la
fin de l'année 2021 pour les premiers
parcours mais sans se mettront
évidemment quelques mois de plus mais ça
ni vous ni moi ne pouvons quoi que ce
soit monsieur le sénateur je voulais
répondre sur la question des examens
visée neurologique
en fait c'est le mieux c'est le conseil
d'état qui nous enjoint
à supprimer le recours aux techniques à
visée neurologique il demande
d'interdire expressément l'irm
fonctionnelle à des fins judiciaires et
elle nous prémunir contre le
détournement ou la surinterprétation des
usages de cette technique à des fins
judiciaires
par exemple le détecteur de mensonges
pour statuer sur la culpabilité de
quelqu'un vous savez que ce n'est pas
possible dans notre pays sur
l'amendement qui a été adopté au sénat
en première lecture y avait un risque
inconstitutionnelle il n'appartient pas
au pouvoir réglementaire de limiter par
décret des moyens de preuve dont dispose
les juges
voilà un endroit les raisons pour
lesquelles nous sommes revenus en
deuxième lecture ne proposait de revenir
sur les dispositions telles qu'adoptées
par le sénat oui well excusez moi je me
rends compte qu'on a effectivement
oublié de répondre aussi à votre
première question à manama sénatrice
colonnes sur les deux régimes différents
effectivement bon là aussi enfin sans
vouloir botter en touche comme on dit et
le gardien sera probablement l'occasion
de revenir sur ce sujet là mais
effectivement c'est le régime qui a été
le adopte qui a été élaboré et qui nous
semblait et qui semblait au ministère de
la justice le plus sécurisant notamment
pour la filiation des enfants et est le
plus égalitaire aussi même si
effectivement créé deux régimes
différents
mais en tout cas c'est le compromis qui
a été trouvé afin d'assurer la filiation
et de sécuriser notamment du point de
vue de l'enfant l'affiliation aux
couples aux couples de femmes
voilà après après de nombreux nombreuses
réflexions de nombreux échanges sur
cette question là notamment au cours de
la navette parlementaire puisque sauf
erreur c'est ma mémoire est bonne
c'était pas forcément le dispositif qui
avait été initialement initialement
prévu si mes souvenirs sont bons par le
par le garde des sceaux de l'époque
nicole belloubet merci bien
donc maintenant je vais céder la parole
à victor à jasmin oui merci monsieur le
président merci messieurs les ministres
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
le conseil génétique ce conseil
génétique particulièrement pour tout ce
qui concerne les différentes
hémoglobinopathies et particulièrement
sur les panneaux site aux et les
thalassémie
alors le d'une part le diagnostic
néonatale se fait déjà mais ne se fait
pas par tous le territoire
on voit de plus en plus naître des
enfants qui seraient les panneaux 6/3 et
c'est un serment à la naissance que les
parents en les formations donc
maintenant que nous travaillons sur ce
texte en deuxième lecture c'est vrai je
suis fier en tout cas monsieur le
ministre que vous puissiez trouver les
moyens du temps si fier le conseil
génétique particulièrement sur ces
aspects là parce que ce même si
aujourd'hui en termes de paix
thérapeutique il y a les avancées il ya
également des greffes osseuses il ya des
thérapies génique qui sont là il ya un
certain nombre de dispositions mais on
voit encore net retrait trop souvent les
enfants drépanocytaires sans que les
parents soient informés au préalable
dans place c'est une particulière tout
simplement pas et comme il ya le volet
conseil génétique et puis il est aussi
question selon moi de le voir des
différents professionnels qui pourrait
évidemment être habilité pour faire ce
qu'on sait génétique en fonction du
territoire et de les former pour qu'ils
aient l'intégrité des informations
particulièrement sur ces aspects là je
vous remercie
merci bien monsieur karoutchi pour la
suite
j'avais trouvé un qui marche pas
m'étonne pas monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres moi je ne suis
pas un progressiste pragmatique je suis
un conservateur pragmatique sur ce texte
au sénat
j'ai voté pour la pma pour l'extension
la pma mais je me suis abstenu sur
l'ensemble après avoir interpellé madame
busin à l'époque quand je lui ai dit
madame la ministre
voilà le texte du sénat il va partir à
l'assemblée dites-moi ce que le
gouvernement va avoir comme position par
rapport à ce texte global et par rapport
à ce que va demander l'assemblée et
lorsque madame vu un mehdi par
définition nous ne conserveront pas le
texte du sénat sur une bonne partie des
éléments
j'ai considéré que je n'allais pas me
ridiculiser à voter pour le texte
pour savoir que le gouvernement allait
ensuite faire en sorte que ce texte ne
soit en rien celui de l'assemblée
bien en a pris puisque
je vois bien que le texte qui reviennent
l'assemblée a passablement charcuter le
texte qui est sorti du sénat je
considère que vous avez raison monsieur
le ministre la loi cours souvent après
la pratique mais pour autant la
responsabilité du législateur
elle est aussi d'accepter les évolutions
de les mettre en musique de les encadrer
de faire en sorte que l'évolution
sociétale ne soit pas forcément quelque
chose qui n'est pas de ce cadre précis
sinon ça veut dire que dès qu' il ya une
évolution dans la société on l'acceptent
on légifère dessus on accepte que
l'évolution ce quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs soit la loi et ça ce n'est
pas possible sinon autant dire qu'il ya
plus de parlement et que les réseaux
sociaux suffisent donc moi ma question
elle est extrêmement simple messieurs
les ministres
on va avoir ce long débat encore au
sénat j'imagine imagine que sur la
filiation que sur ce dont parlait madame
cohen et j'ai souvenir d'avoir soutenu
l'amendement du groupe crc à l'époque
sur un certain nombre d'éléments sur
l'encadrement de la pma qu'est-ce qui
vous apparaît essentiel en fait parce
que moi ce qui m'apparaissait
essentielle dans ce texte au point de
départ c'était de dire on crée un droit
nouveau
l'extension de la pma mais dans mon
esprit il fallait que le reste ne soient
pas des éléments qui puissent choquer
tel ou tel et que l'on puisse encadrer
et avancer ensemble tous ensemble
est ce que si on vote
comme la fois précédente au sénat un
certain nombre d'éléments le
gouvernement puisque effectivement la
navette doit continuer le gouvernement
peut évoluer avec nous avancer avec nous
ou bien est ce que vous considérez que
par définition vous avez une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et que même s'il
ya bien des éléments transgreen est ce
que vous ne considérez pas que ce serait
quand même mieux que sur les textes
en tout cas sur les textes bioéthique on
arrive non pas à des consensus on n'y
arrivera jamais mais en tout cas à des
situations où la plus grande partie des
élus se sentent concernés impliqués
associés et que la société française
puisse évoluer de manière plus sereine
et moins par à coups voilà moi je je je
ne sais pas ce que je ferai cette fois
ci si franchement j'ai le sentiment que
ça ne sert à rien de faire avancer je ne
changerais peut-être de vote mais parce
que arrive un moment où il faut qui est
quand même un suivi c'est à dire le
gouvernement peut demander au parlement
le soutien sur un texte sur des éléments
lourds mais le parlementaire peut aussi
demander au gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui vous apparaît essentiel
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour qu
ans le sénat et l'assemblée arrive à un
accord
si c'est pour être au final battu par un
texte de l'assemblée qui ne reprend en
rien les éléments du sénat
sincèrement c'est la procédure
on va la respecter mais elle me paraît
excessivement longue pour un rapport de
force et non pas un rapport de consensus
merci monsieur chasse à merci monsieur
le président messieurs les ministres
donc moi j'ai favorables à cette loi
puisque en fait les femmes seules en
couple aller à l'étranger à condition
d'avoir suffisamment d'argent et c'est
donc une avancée sociale et ce au site
sociétale mais après monsieur karoutchi
je vais poser quelques questions c'est
vrai que notamment
sur ce qui est dit et c'est la mère de
ce qui a été demandé aux qui était
proposée par cela c'est d'informer
l'enfant avant sa majorité qu'il est né
d'un don peu d'enfants le demandent et
dans les études que j'ai que j'ai lu
mais il ya effectivement il ya peu
d'enfants qu'il demande est en fait
l'anonymat c'était aussi pour protéger
les parents les donneurs et l'enfant une
autre question aussi sur le consentement
du conjoint qui va être son anonymat va
être levé et le donneur son conjoint
doit dans c'est ce qu'avait décidé le
céda de pouvoir donner son avis enfin la
console la conservation des gamètes dans
des établissements à but lucratif
puisqu'il n'y aura pas ces
établissements et enfin une dernière
question sur le dpi
beaucoup de femmes bon aussi à
l'étranger parce que après plus beaucoup
de fécondation in vitro peut y avoir
beaucoup de fausses couches liés à des
anomalies chromosomiques et en france de
dpi donc ne sera pas autorisé donc je
pense que c'était aussi quelque chose
d'important pour ces femmes qui font des
fausses couches à répétition merci merci
bien je vous laisse répondre à une
question qui portait sur le conseil
génétique madame la sénatrice moyen de
densifier vous prenez l'exemple de la
drépanocytose
le sdm impact en plus spécifiquement
certaines donc j'attends des preuves des
pas des drépanocytaires pardon lui est
ce qu'on appelle le sdm impact en plus
spécifiquement certaines populations des
pistes le dépistage est aujourd'hui
ciblées en france métropolitaine en
fonction de l'origine géographique des
personnes
des parents et il est proposé à tous les
nouveaux nés en territoires ultramarins
ce ciblage il avait besoin d'une
réévaluation pour voir s'il était
toujours d'actualité ou non afin de
faire évoluer son petit la haute
autorité de santé qui est chargé de le
faire je ne vais pas vous mentir on
attendait un avis de la haute autorité
de santé en 2020
il a été retardé compte tenu de la crise
sanitaire et de des multiples travaux
que nous demandons à la chaise dans la
période mais ils devraient arriver
prochainement c'est un point qu'on
regarde sur la question d'ailleurs plus
généralement sur le conseil génétique en
outre mer c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il
ya très peu de conseils génétique en
outre-mer pas suffisamment en tout cas
et donc il y a
des naissances nombreuses de personnes
attein drépanocytose sans information
préalable des parents pour ça que
l'article 25 du projet de loi qui
prévoit l'extension des missions des
conseillers en génétique de manière à
pouvoir développer l'offre avec une
attention particulière qui sera portée
aux territoires ultramarins sur monsieur
le sénateur karoutchi alors pardon mais
comme je n'étais pas au banc en première
lecture je ne sais pas sur la la nature
des articles qui avait emporté un vote
de neutralité et auquel vous êtes
finalement sur quels articles et quatre
amendements quel apport du sénat vous
étiez particulièrement attachés parce
que parfois on est attaché à certains
des amendements qui ont été adoptés pas
forcément à tous d'ailleurs l'assemblée
nationale nous dit la même chose et même
nous comme gouvernement on était très
attaché à certains articles en état et
d'autres qu'on a pu faire évoluer c'est
aussi 2 ainsi qu'un texte évolué mais
vous avez beaucoup plus d' expertise que
moi en la matière et d'expérience mais
on a il ya des choses qu'on n'a pas
gardé oui qui avait été adopté par le
sénat
la non prise en charge par l'assurance
maladie de la pma moi je pense que c'est
normal que ce soit l'assurance maladie
qui le prennent en charge
et donc ça je peux vous dire que je
aubin je tiendrai une position ferme sur
cette question il faut que la mp
puissent être prises en charge par
l'assurance maladie
on vient de se dire que l'obstacle
financier était et est inégalitaire
inéquitable et que les femmes qui
pouvaient mettre de côté 5000 euros pour
partir à l'étranger pourrait bénéficier
d'une pma celles qui ne pouvaient pas
d'en bénéficier pas on va pas créer un
obstacle au sein au sein même de notre
territoire avec une technique qui serait
reconnu comme comme autorisé légale et
par ailleurs on a rétabli l'article 2
sur l'autoroute sur l'auto conservation
également qui est un point qui est
important est que nous défendrons
également deuxième lecture au sénat
par contre il ya des choses qu'on a
gardé des travaux des sénateurs
l'article 7 ter sur le don du corps
l'article sur tours don du sang par les
mêmes pour les majeurs protégés ce que
vous aviez un peu ce qu'ils avaient dans
le sens de ce que vous aviez dix
sénateurs juillet les questions les
enjeux sur le dépistage néonatal mais
également l'article 2 sur l'ouverture au
privé que j'avais moi même défendu
d'ailleurs au parlement en première
lecture sans succès mais que j'ai pu
défendre au banc en deuxième lecture
avec succès donc il a été il ay pu être
aussi
conserver c'est important de le dire
donc après je ne sais pas si ça répond à
votre question si vous voulez plus
précis dans les skis vous faisait
vraiment ce qui vous tenait à coeur et
pour le sénateur chassaing sur le don
anonyme peut-être que tu veux
répondre oui et ce sera peut-être aussi
un élément de réponse peut-être j'espère
à direction du sénateur karoutchi parce
que monsieur le sénateur chassaing sur
cette question
2 effectivement la possibilité pour les
deux parents bénéficiaires de l'aeeh
disposer d'informations identifiantes
avant la majorité de l'enfant
c'est plutôt une disposition à laquelle
gouvernement et est opposé et moi même
d'ailleurs qui était au banc à ce moment
là lors des débats à l'assemblée
nationale et défendu plutôt une position
contraire parce que ça induisent est
selon moi
paradoxalement au nom de l'intérêt de
l'enfant parce que ça introduisez une
asymétrie est que dans toutes les
familles tout ne se passe pas toujours
bien et que mettre dans les mains des
parents ce type d'information dans des
cadres conflictuelle me semblait pouvoir
porter atteinte à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant et donc c'est un aspect sur
lequel si la commission les rapporteurs
veulent poursuivre la réflexion
notamment étayé ça de façon technique ça
sera un point monsieur le sénateur
karoutchi sur lequel le gouvernement
pourra évoluer et faire en sorte que ce
texte soit un peu plus encore ce que moi
je considère être un texte plutôt
consensuelle des débats qui ont été
plutôt apaisé et constructif et dans
l'hémicycle et dans la société
le ministre le répétait je crois que si
c'est peut-être huit articles ont été
adoptés conforme et et je crois que les
pointes peut-être d'opposition entre le
gouvernement et le sénat je crois sont
un peu sans surprise d'ailleurs sont
conformes aussi à ce que le gouvernement
avait pu émettre comme position dès le
début voilà mais en tout cas sur ce
point là je gagne une porte ouverte pour
des pour des échanges alors
par anticipation aussi d'autres
questions du sénateur chassaing sur le
dauphin sur la concernant au sol et la
conservation par des centres privés oui
j'ai déjà répondu du coup c'était votre
commission sénatoriale qui l'avait
introduit en première lecture au sénat
il y avait un avis défavorable du
gouvernement en lecture dans l'hémicycle
sénatoriales et les sénateurs avaient
voté contre
ça a été réintroduit à l'assemblée
nationale complétée d'une interdiction
de dépassement temps d'ailleurs dans les
établissements publics pour l'activité
libérale des praticiens hospitaliers que
pour les autres et donc le gouvernement
avait donné un avis favorable
on avait repris de la proposition votre
commission merci nous continuons avec la
présidente de roche
merci président avant de devenir au
point de la question qui concerne
l'article 20 mois je voulais préciser un
peu aussi comme roger karoutchi
comment j'avais été pour ma part un peu
choquée de la façon abrupte dont la
ministre busin avait terminé le débat
alors que nous avions sur beaucoup de
points étaient parfois en phase avec
elle sur des sujets je pense par exemple
à faire d utiliser en post mortem des
dons de gamètes et autres et en effet sa
conclusion dix ans mais toutes façons
tout sera revu à l'assemblée nationale
m'avait paru assez plus conforme à
l'ensemble du débat et je pense qu'en
effet on en avait tous étaient un peu
choqués bon ma question c'est l'article
20 il a été rajouté concernant les mg de
façon très précise que le père elle
pouvait résulter d'une détresse
psychosociale or cette détresse elle est
déjà prise en compte dans les par les
équipes qui pratiquent des interruptions
médicales de grossesse donc pourquoi
avoir
introduit ceci en plus puisque ça existe
déjà et pourquoi faire primer ce critère
sur d'autres en le mettant ainsi en
exergue
c'était ma question merci nous avons
tous un moment ou un autre des moments
de lassitude d'exaspération monsieur
salvan oui bien sûr
merci messieurs les ministres
le groupe écologiste dont je fais parti
salue déjà les avancées notables de ce
texte après cette deuxième lecture
donc voila nous souhaitons le noter je
reviendrai simplement sur l'article 4
qui avait déjà été évoquée plusieurs
fois
nous pensons aussi que il aurait été
tellement plus simple d'appliquer le
droit commun pour un couple de femmes
qui faisaient une pma plutôt que
d'ajouter un autre un droit une
exception qui a tendance une fois de
plus a troublé et à créer de la
confusion donc voilà je pense que quand
on peut faire simple faisons simple le
second point concerne les opérations qui
sont effectués sur les personnes
concernées par des variations de
développement sexuel
donc c'est on en a déjà parlé mais donc
ces opérations qui visent à leur
assigner insectes sont fait parfois très
tôt et ne sont pas sans poser de deux
grands soucis de souffrance se sont
parfois c'est parfois perçus comme des
mutilations
nous pensons qu'il faudrait lorsque ce
n'est pas une question vitale attendre
que l'enfant ait déjà parfois le temps
d'exprimer son choix parce que des fois
on fait des opérations on va dire
prématurément
cela touche effectivement peu d'enfants
puisque sur huit cent mille naissances
en france à peu près 200 enfants qui
sont concernés chaque année semée c'est
quand même deux cents enfants ça a
tendance d'ailleurs s'accroît t en tant
qu'écologiste bien entendu nous faisons
le lien avec des pollutions
environnementales pour une part et c'est
ce sont des causes qui sont déjà avancés
dans de nombreuses études donc il
faudrait s'attacher aussi à à la base
voilà donc je pense que nous nous
déposerons un amendement concernant le
fait que nous puissions attendre que
lorsque c'est possible que l'enfant
donne son avis sur le sexe qu'il
construit le considère qui va être le
sien merci merci bien madame meunier
p'tit monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et veyran vous avez dit au
début de l'audition que parfois les
pratiques précédait la loi vous avez
vous avez raison et donc enfin
législateur doit se faire un peu
bousculée moi je voulais vous interroger
sur les aspects de calendrier enfin
plutôt les modalités de révision de
cette loi vous avez dit aussi au début
de notre rencontre là vous avez parlé de
cinq ans oui voilà c'est ça c'est bien
ça donc
donc c'est de 7 ans puisqu'il ya eu un
article 32 là qui a donc précisé sept
ans après promulgation de la loi
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est pas un
peu trop se dire que celle ci était déjà
en fin 2011 à la dernière donc ça fait
10 ans et compte tenu de la rapidité pas
à la fois de la recherche mais aussi des
comportements ou des évolutions
sociétales est-ce que vous pensez que
sept ans est une bonne bonne temporalité
en sachant que l'article 32 parle aussi
de l' évaluation tous les quatre ans par
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation nos
textes
voilà donc là dessus monsieur merci
madame agnès c'est une question que je
vais vous poser monsieur ministre sur
les cinq ans à l'époque la loi
précédente de bioéthique
je m'étais le rapporteur au sénat et
j'avais déjà eu des relations avec le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement d'époque concernant sept ans
ou cinq ans et c'est cela qui a fait
passer à 5 ans et je souhaite que le
sénat fasse passer à 5 ans je laisse la
parole à monsieur le ministre
alors oui donc pardon sur la question
des 5 ans du 7 ans était la sagesse
laisser aux législateurs gouvernement
n'a pas pris parti après je veux dire je
si on prend la question des tests
génétiques par exemple parce que ça
tient sept ans vu l'évolution des
techniques vue l'a vu l'attrait pour les
gens aujourd'hui c'est encore un gadget
mais enfin demain si on voit qu'il ya
une utilité
ce n'est pas la voie qui le freinera
dont quelque chose qui sont amenés à
réviser plus vite ce qu'est ce qui est
certain c'est qu'avec ce qu'on appelle
les ntic nouveau biotechnologies
l'informatique la cognition n'a jamais
eu la génomique
ça va tellement vite ça j'ai voulu
tellement vite que ça nous forcera
forcément nécessairement on aura on ira
se poser des questions le faso qui nous
succéderont auront des questions restent
posées plus plus fréquemment que ça et à
côté de ça le temps les stats il peut
être très long mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je crois que la loi autorisant la
recherche sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires
elle a pris 15 ans et la france a pris
un retard considérable
j'étais député au banc lorsque il y
avait eu encore une mise en échec par
les parle par les députés l'opposition
de l'époque de cette loi on avait repris
encore un an
et puis finalement on se rend compte que
maintenant que c'est autorisé ça
fonctionne très bien et personne n'est
revenu de revenir dessus
j'entends même parfois certains députés
qui avaient voté contre à l'époque
s'étonner que la recherche biomédicale
française ne voit pas plus avancé que ça
peut-être que si on se donnait les
moyens de législatives pour permettre à
la recherche de se développer sans avoir
de peur qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
fondée on irait encore plus vite donc
moi je reste très très modeste par
rapport à notre capacité à trouver le
bon timing pour réviser les lois de
bioéthique
ça accélère considérablement donc moi je
vous dirai si vous ne souhaitez pas le
ca cinq ans le gouvernement dira sagesse
si vous le souhaitez de baisser à 7 ans
gouvernement dira sagesse voit la
sagesse le dessinateur sur cette
question sur liège et psychosocial de
madame la présidente de la commission
lmc psychosocial ce que j'avais compris
ce que j'ai compris de débats entre en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
c'est que au fond la pratique existe
elle est légale mais les inéquitablement
comprise sur le territoire national et
donc certaines équipes en charge
déterminer si une nième je pouvais être
fait ou non avait une lecture du droit
qui n'était pas forcément la même que
les équipes de territoires voisins
et donc j'ai plus vu dans cet amendement
porté par des parlementaires une forme
de rappel à la loi une ouverture de
droits et j'ai entendu des réactions
parfois extrêmement vicieux de gens qui
considérait que là on avait porté une
atteinte incroyable à l'existant et que
on avait fait évoluer en catimini le
droit en réalité tous les juristes vous
le diront le droit n'a pas évolué en
tant que tel c'est un rappel dans le
droit qui clarifie le droit déjà
existants et donc le gouvernement à
donner un avis de sagesse là aussi au
banc comme quand vous voyez monsieur le
sénateur karoutchi cuir de ne pas donner
sens et plusieurs fois remis à sagesse
des parlementaires
considérant que cet état un additif à
une loi qui ne rajoute rien au droit
mais qu'ils pouvaient en améliorer la
compréhension
donc les députés ont décidé de voter
pour jeux suivront les débats au sénat
sur cette question s'ils ont lieu
sur voila moi j'ai répondu m à partir
avait encore une question c'est les
variations sexuelle pour adrien taquet
oui monsieur le sénateur sur 7 sur ce
sujet là et en complément des éléments
transmis effectivement à la sénatrice
cohen redire que l' équilibre nous
semble avoir été trouvé dans la
formulation adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale que c'est une fois encore plus
tôt dans l'esprit des recommandations du
comité consultatif national d'éthique et
de sa recommandation 132 et puis que au
final la la la question est celle de
l'âme de la nécessité médicale ou pas en
réalité c'est ça la question à laquelle
les professionnels de santé sont
confrontés dans ce genre de situation et
il appartient et nous devons me
semble-t-il laissé aux professionnels de
santé
l'opportunité d'apprécier ou pas la
nécessité médicale et s'est mis aux
législateurs et ni au gouvernement non
plus de l'apprécier cela ou de
systématiser forcément ce genre de
position est plutôt de laisser cette
appréciation professionnels de santé qui
sont confrontés au cas par cas à ces
situations là c'est ça la position
d'équilibré je crois qu'il a été trouvé
qui me semble relever de la sagesse ou
alors donc c'est plutôt cette position
nous continuerons de défendre
merci y at il encore des questions
non bien messieurs les ministres vous
aurez largement le temps d'aller à vos
pots à vos réunions suivantes
merci en tout cas de tous et de toutes
ces réponses constructives et puis
rendez vous bientôt en séance sur le
sujet
[Musique]